hey y'all it's andrew couch here in this
how to use a video we're going to be
going over some of the lesser-known
packages
from the ensemble tidy models package
but before i start this video i wanted
to say that
i have a link in the description below
for my q a video for my one year
anniversary
so if you have any questions you want to
ask me uh open up the link and submit me
a question it's coming up uh pretty soon
i believe it's going to come up
basically in
less than a month so i'm very excited to
um celebrate my one year anniversary
with a q a video
so the main reason why i wanted to make
a video kind of outlining the lesser
known tidy models packages
is because tidy models comes with more
packages
that i think people aren't really aware
about especially since when you run
tidy models um using like the library
function it only loads
up the the core packages right so our
sample parsnip recipes
are sick etc but there are some very
specialized smaller packages
that can be pretty useful for your
day-to-day work
and i didn't want to make a vid
individual video for each package
because
generally the packages that aren't the
core italian models packages
are very small and do not contain a
a lot of functions so i figured i'd make
like a high level overview
of you know i think of the packages that
i think would be pretty useful
um given your situation so the first
kind of
parts of the uh smaller packages is
basically just models
um i think one criticism with parsnip
is that there's not a lot of models that
are available for the tide and models
framework
however um tidy models does actually
include
four packages um that have a little bit
more um
specific models that could be used so
not just your random force but
some more useful things that are
definitely more sats based
over machine learning focused so the
first package i'm going to go over is
the poisson reg
package and i think with this package
name
it's basically about fitting poisson
models i'm using tiny models
so if you're dealing with a lot of like
count data uh or interval data
um the poisson reg package is probably
it's probably gonna be pretty useful for
you
um especially if you understand like the
like you're
oh if you understand your data structure
follows like a poisson distribution
they're trying to predict or gain some
type of inference um and as you can see
when you do the reference
there's only just one function which is
a poisson reg
which basically creates the poisson
model and you have these two parameters
obviously you can fit it with different
back ends so i think the most popular
would be
maybe like glm or stan um but uh it's
pretty straightforward
they come with different poisson models
too so you can do like a zero inflated
poisson
i think you can even do a near zero
inflator or something like that
but um so it's basically a basic
modeling on package that you can do
uh if you want to fit some puts on
models
um and then the next package is actually
the pls
mod so the part which is about like
partially squares uh models
and i really don't use this model this
package at all uh even
even in my work but you know you can
just use the pls function
so partially squares um again it
could be very useful um if you're
dealing with like very wide data sets
stuff like that but for me since i'm
really focused more on
like a business problems uh you don't
actually have to you don't really see
that many
um very wide and short data sets instead
uh
you know you only have a decent you only
have like a few features with a large
amount of samples
on there pretty much have a near zero
variance
um so the pls mod package
could be useful i guess if you're
wrecking chemistry or in biostatistics
or something like that
but for me uh i don't really use it a
lot but
it is a very straightforward package
uh just like the entire tiny models
framework you know you can use
just the pls function and just fit your
model
you would do anywhere anytime else so
you use your i think
predictor proportion or num components
um so nothing too crazy pretty easy and
i can see why they wouldn't include this
in the the core
packages but if you need to use it you
don't have to change away from tiny
models you can just
up uh you can just load in the pls mod
package
so another modeling framework is the
rules package
so this is all about obviously rule
based models
um again i still don't wouldn't use this
too much too many times but um one of
the benefits of using these types of
i guess packages is that um
they can um you can use multiple
predictions
so you can basically use the trees or
the individual trees or that you can
even set the number of trees you want to
use
from an ensemble method like you know
bagging models
so um this is a pretty useful um package
if you want to do like multi-predict
um and stuff like that but again i
usually just use random forests
or maybe even a decision tree so i don't
really use it too much but
uh it's pretty straightforward you know
you can use your c5 models or cubist
model
and then you can also just do um you
know the the randomly selected
predictors using um
rules so
i kind of confused the the rules
packaged with the baguette package but
the baguette package actually does a lot
of ensembling which i think
out of all the packages i just showed is
one of the more useful packages
because uh you can do all this uh
bagging via i guess bootstrap
aggregation um and this is very useful
because
instead of just training a random force
model you can just do use a baguette
package
and it'll train up a little bit faster
and the model will be a little bit
smaller
so if you're trying to do a lot of
deployment or doing a lot of testing uh
this can be very useful
um and again this it follows basically
the same thing as a modeling framework
so you can do
bagged mars models bagged trees um
stuff like that and then you can do like
variable importance and you can do
control bag
um i definitely would probably use
bagtry probably the most because it's
just the same
essentially just you know fitting a
bunch of um
decision tree models using cart um and
then uh
ensembling them by like uh through votes
and stuff like that
um so once you do the bag tree uh you
can do the multi
prediction i think or something like
that you um
so you do that and you can kind of get a
good idea of like how you're training
your models and stuff like that
so the last um i guess model
extension is the discrim package or for
discriminating analysis models
and this is the one package that i
probably use the most outside of
um the core tidy models and i like to
use this
especially when i'm doing a very like ad
hoc analysis
um plus you have access to a naive bayes
model
which i'm a huge fan of because i think
naive bayes models although have
very strict assumptions um are kind of
fine actually in the
in practice and you can definitely
violate these assumptions and get
pretty good performance with pretty good
speeds
so i for me i use the discrim package a
lot um
mostly to just use the naive bayes model
but you can obviously have there's like
a flexible description flexible
discriminatory analysis some linear
discriminant models
um all this type of stuff where it's
definitely pretty useful
um especially if you're going to do more
like interpretive models and get
some type of analytic insight um
so yeah these um are definitely the
screen package and the baguette package
are probably the most
useful packages outside of the parsnip
core
models so another smaller package that i
believe i've actually
used in
in my videos or just the embed package i
i think i've also used it with like
maybe it's actually with the um the
text recipes package but embed package
is
all about embeddings um and for me i
really don't need to do a lot of like
numerical embeddings so
not really trying to do a uh like
numerical embeddings or
stuff like that but mostly if i'm
dealing with variables that have
a lot of levels to it so in this case
they use like the
the zip code example um
where you know you might have when
you're trying to predict a price you may
know that
uh yeah your your neighborhood uh
definitely has an effect on the price
but the levels are so large that you
want to do some type of embeddings on it
so
you don't have to have as many terms
into
a model so the embed package definitely
is pretty useful if you're dealing with
like highly sparse data or data with a
lot of levels
um they do have um some interesting
um i guess transformations so that you
can do
weight of evidence encodings future
hashing
layer embeddings using keras or using a
neural network
um stuff like that but i really don't
use it a lot
um if i were to use a function i'd
probably use step in bed
using the keras uh package just to make
my own little embeddings
from that i will say i don't have really
a lot of experience doing like bins
for numeric predictors um but that could
be useful
uh i've never really seen it to be that
useful to be honest but
it is something that you could try out
uh if you're kind of tinkering with some
models
okay and then finally this is one
package that i think
probably has one of the most um widely
uh useful uh features which is the uh
applicable or applicable package so
in this case it's kind of used for
chemistry where they're talking about
how
you know sometimes when you're you're
messing and experimenting with samples
using a model
some of these samples uh are not
realistic
to see in the real life right so it's
not a like
realistic uh in the in the in the wild
so a lot of this time all these times is
when you're making a model
or something like that uh you might deal
with some data sets that
are just outliers due to like data
quality or stuff like that
where you realistically know that you
know even though my mom
might predict uh a positive on the on
the sample
we know that this this sample isn't
actually real or realistic to even see
so we can actually kind of adjust and
say like okay well maybe we're not that
sure that
um this model should actually be
outputting that so
this is a very useful package um you can
use it for both like
you know classification problems um
or regression problems it essentially uh
scores it and stuff like that by using
like on some pca
and seeing how far it is from uh was it
the
components right um so it's pretty
interesting to see
um where basically your samples are are
ending up
uh and if you are seeing like any new
samples
of how how close it is to your actual
model training data so again this is a
very
uh useful package essentially you're
trying to do
like you know if you're deploying a
model you're seeing some
you know changes some fluctuations in
the prediction accuracy
um that might be useful to kind of check
your um
applicability domain and see like oh
maybe our date our entire data is just
fundamentally changed or maybe we were
just using bad data
um to train a model but those are the
main packages that i thought were pretty
interesting
um this is definitely not going to be a
um
this this this video is going to be very
dated i'm sure in like three months
but a good way to check um whether
there's any new packages that they're
working on
or just kind of be able to test it out
yourself is it go on github.com
tidy models and kind of just go through
um
the actual repos of each package
so with like recipes you can kind of see
like where are they adding you know
read the poll requests see what new
features they're going to be adding to
it
and stuff like that so all nominal
predictors and all numeric predictors
that would be a pretty interesting um
recipe
step so you can just you know do your
dummying it's on on
and stuff like that um so again
there's a lot of interesting things i
will say that um you can also see like
new packages that they're building so
in this case when i was looking at it
they're they're making a lantern package
so
a tidy models uh framework using um
the torch package so it'd be kind of
interesting to see like
a tidy model's implementation of neural
networks and
what i would like to see is like a tidy
model's implementation of more complex
like multi-layered
neural networks so deep learning with
tiny models would be
a very interesting thing to see i'm not
sure if this one will actually do it or
not
um but a lot of stuff is pretty
interesting
to look at and it's always good to kind
of just look at these repos
you know read the poll requests read the
comments read the issues and just kind
of see how
what people are thinking about um from
different domains so
what's cool about it is you know people
who are talking on on the lantern
repo you know they might they're
definitely going to be more focused on
on
on neural networks but you can also see
like what they're kind of thinking about
when they're trying to design
uh a package to fit you know as a whole
data science needs and not just one
specific need
so i know this is a pretty quick video
um i wanted to make a video based on
kind of the remaining packages from tiny
models
um but i am going to be making
a series on you know starting your
project starting side project by
yourself
um and we're going to basically do it
from start to finish so we're going to
do like data
scraping data cleaning feature
engineering
modeling and deployment so this will
probably be
um coming up next week and i'll probably
split up into like a three or four part
series
uh so i'm looking forward to that but in
the meantime i will see you guys next
week and tidy on